ouah mais qu'est ce qui nous est arrivé
cinq vidéos sans sombrer dit c'est ce
qu'on a pendant un instant arrêté de
céder à la facilité
waouh bon aujourd'hui ce n'est pas lié à
une nouvelle passion ou un truc un
délire en ce moment pas du tout ça fait
bien d'ailleurs parce que quand je dis
ça j'ai passé mauvais signe
c'est que je vais beaucoup investir
c'est un truc qui vaut très peu le coup
bref youth et des chips et le nom du
jeune fredy d'aujourd'hui qui veut dire
littéralement oh là là t'as vu sa chérie
c'est une traduction adaptée aux
annonceurs
on essaie d'être ennemis vous savez ce
samedi dit en gros c'est simple c'est
juste des trucs impressionnants avoirs
ou des réactions impressionnante avoir
un peu comme good people die zeit qu'on
avait fait la dernière fois est ce que
vous êtes prêts quel plaisir de refaire
un sommet dit j'ai plus l'habitude on
perd vite l'habitude c'est fou tout ça
c'est de la poudre aux yeux
alors évidemment je les classe par les
meilleurs de tous les temps puisqu'on
est là uniquement pour voir le meilleur
des meilleurs tous les temps sinon on
perd notre temps en fait c'est parti
[Musique]
puis je revois c'est allé très vite puis
je revois mais comment c'est possible
j'ai un 5e set up c'est tellement c'est
surréaliste mot bravo au touquet à cet
homme très agile avec ses on voit que le
lancer est totalement maîtrisé il doit
te soulevé à la pétanque monga ce type
c'est évident il doit être insupportable
doit toujours c'est robert leroy des
pays bas montre une vidéo au premier
ministre des pays-bas pendant un speech
de trump c'est vraiment nous au collège
mais quarante ans plus tard ça donne ça
[Musique]
ça me fout wouah ça valait le coup au
moins ça valait le coup alors le glitch
and the matrix
[Musique]
ah ah ah non ça en fout c'est très drôle
il leur reflet elle peut pas re y croire
il n'a pas peur de se prendre une bonne
claque à ce ça me fait bander ça se
trouve toutes les fois j'ai cru avoir
fait une action et qu'en fait non je
n'avais pas fait parce que tout était
encore à l'endroit numéro un by ap ce
gala ce mec avec ses dreads là comme ça
cache et qui me rendais foule est venue
chez nous tout ce mec pour nous faire ça
au revoir et le roi du maroc sans
d'ordre pendant ce pitch de macron
château la france salue avec respect et
gravité les mains des autres nations que
jadis
elle a combattu rien devant je pense ils
ont un planning il ya des moments dans
l'année où bon après je vais pas
défendre ce qui est peut-être
indéfendable attention je pense qu'il ya
des périodes de l'année où ils bougent
énormément et ce qu'ils auront un rendez
vous dans un pays puis dans un mot puis
tu sais toi toi t'as rendez-vous dans
l'arrondissement d'à côté où la région
d'à côté eux c'est dans le pays de
l'autre côté du globe et du coup je
pense que quand il enchaîne beaucoup ben
wallace assad et tu peux t'en dormir là
malheureusement le roi du maroc s'est
endormi sur un speech de commémoration
aux soldats morts donc c'est un peu baba
fort bref watts qui ce qu ce pour quoi
faire
elle voulait le recouvrir du talent
j'ai pas compris le propos chez mes mecs
mais c'est fait exprès quel intérêt de
recouvrir un ballon de baudruche
entièrement de pâte à tartiner tête je
suis passé à côté de quelque chose dans
mon enfance
peut-être c'est totalement normal et
personne ne comprend pas pourquoi je
suis étonné de sa skoda psychoter hawass
a séduit le skate revient beaucoup à la
mode et ça me fait très plaisir
c'est relou parce que nous on met genre
deux ans à apprendre à faire un bout qui
plaît et ça n'impressionne plus personne
à cause des gens comme lui parce que
tout le monde voit ce que des gens comme
lui ont fait et les gens comme nous un
peu basique du coup ils n'arrivent plus
à impressionner fait chier il est dehors
tous les jours à attendre du jeu le
nourrissent aujourd'hui je voulais voir
à quel point je peux m'approcher de lui
oh c'est marrant parce qu'il ya pas
longtemps je suis allé raconter ma vie
ça longtemps je suis allé à dans le parc
et acté de buckingham palace je crois
que prononce comme sa demi finale à
londres et en fait c'est un parc où il
ya pleins pleins d'écureuil un peu comme
au canada à montréal il ya plein de
[ __ ] laveur enfin plainte en croise
régulièrement tout comme en guadeloupe
tu croises régulièrement des iguanes et
à chaque fois tu vois les touristes dans
ces zones-là du monde parce que c'est
les seuls qui sont sensibles à ces bêtes
là parce qu'il y en a pas chez eux de
simplement donc ils sont en mode hors
regard d'un écureuil incroyable et je me
suis dit [ __ ] mec nous les animaux de
notre vive c'est des pigeons et les
touristes
ils s'en foutent de nos pigeons ils vont
pas leur donner à manger les peut-être
leur faire de trois quarts et c'est tout
non ils les ignorent donc franchement je
propose qu'on lance une cagnotte pour
les pigeons au moins une pétition une
pétition qui s'appelle pourquoi les
pigeons sont sous côté pardo touristes
alors que c'est notre patrimoine à paris
c'est les animaux de parisse et des
bijoux même si ça tourne vraiment
beaucoup les touristes vont se mettre à
les nourrir à prendre soin de lui tout
et on aura des pigeons genre trop beau
bonne santé qui chiron encore plus sur
nos voitures et sur nous je suis parti
loin là mais c'était voilà une pensée
pour les pigeons aux eaux
ça c'est pour nous
[Musique]
cheveux waouh ça joue comme un chat qui
savait que ça a joué comme un chat qui
ça va aller vétérinaire la haye les
aides-soignants des manières on parle
pas de vous les autres ce regard à la
fin toujours son d'armance un viking
100%
ouais je n'y crois pas ces expressions
faciales
[Musique]
il découvre le reptile c'est génial will
eno aussi génial comme il est intrigué
c'est trop bien mais qu'est ce qu'il
faut sortir des [ __ ] de serpent de
caisse v6 délire là c'est trop c'en est
trop pour juste une autre proposition
quel beau gosse regardez-moi ça wow wow
et dallaire gentil et berges août à
l'eonia à abeilles sont trop mignons
allez tout le monde prend son téléphone
et on voit un petit je t'aime à son
partenaire en trick or treat c'est
halloween ça c'est rude halloween je
crois il a des bonbons c'est la
meilleure banque mec s'est foulé ça il a
tout compris
parce qu on est un adulte en a plus
droit de demander des bonbons tuez-les
rageux c'est dommage que ce concept de
prendre quettehou été tirés à son max et
on a tous un peu saturé de ça parce
qu'il ya vraiment des idées qui sont
vraiment bonnes et drôle le problème
c'est qu'elle touche souvent les gens y
trouvent un concept et enfants une vidéo
de 13 14 minutes et du coup au bout de
la troisième minute on peut plus quoi tu
as compris quoi voilà je souhaite
secrètement un retour des prendra les le
retour des banques s'il vous plaît c'est
maintenant
là on dirait le comédien là le gag c'est
la photo du mec qui sort ses yeux l'a
fait le tour du monde plein art mode
saas et moi au japon voilà ça c'est
exactement moi j'aime les bons touristes
aulas mais comment il fait il est trop
fort nous quand vos japon on est à la
place pas de lui mais des autres moi
c'est pas buzzé cette distance moi je
suis fort pareil les rôles le mec il a
une sorte d'appel au pied quoi tu
t'attends à quoi à partir de là et par
dessus tout il un bourdonnement tous les
mecs que j'ai connu dans ma vie qui ont
un bandana
ils sont chauds dans ce qu'ils font des
genres un truc genre un sport ou une
profession ils sont mes gars chaud
dedans ils sont plus forts que ceux qui
n'ont pas le bandana sam accessoires
obligatoires pour être vraiment former
assez fou que j'ai percé sans avoir un
bandana mec quoi
et puis c'est quoi la blague avec ça ah
oui il va le rattraper
on parie combien il va le rattraper à la
petite célébration mais que j'ai jamais
compris cette blague avant de se
retrouver dans cette situation faut
quand même te faire avoir
comment tu peux te faire avoir tiens
prends ce ballet qui est à un mètre du
sol rô le et appuie bien fort au
d'accord je le prends sans regarder ce
qu'il y à là haut j'ai jamais compris
faut être volontaire genre c'est sûr est
ce que tu viens 2
[Musique]
hu et l'incroyable sega voir y aller se
prépare à sortir le carton est ici il a
fait exprès ou pas il a fait exprès ou
pas il a fait exprès ou pas assez
terrible qui m'angoisse
[Musique]
waouh ça elle a trop de chance mais ça
n'arrive qu'une fois dans ta visa de
bien rattrapé en volant sauf qu'elle
s'était filmé pendant que nous on était
seul chez nous à me sentir frais mais
personne ne l'a vu et qu'on le racontera
tout s'en bat les couilles c'est
pitoyable ce genre de moules quand tu
vois ton maître dire good boy à
quelqu'un d'autre
est ce qu'il ya vraiment ça est ce qu'il
ya un peu de ça ou pas quand même avec
les chats sks qui a vraiment de la
jalousie ou est ce qu'on fait des
projections des goûts et du coup on
croyait la jalousie membres et c'est
autre chose
le réflexe de grand père auquel carrie
c'est trop vidéo on voit qu'il est un
peu fier les personnes âgées comme ça
c'est over me statut d'amour et sa gamme
un c'est comme ça que j'en rencontre est
amer
j'aimerais que ça parte de là le vrai
pouvoir
c'est génial
elle a activé le mode décolleté
[Musique]
bon c'est la face à vrai dire j'ai passé
un très bon moment j'ai beaucoup rigolé
ça fait du bien est cinq vidéos sont so
british ça va pas du tout vrai je
m'aperçois que ça m'avait manqué quand
même [ __ ] allez je vous laisse traîner
là sur les réseaux et sur sur crédit
vous connaissez mieux que moi je sais
très bien je vous dis à très vite votre
bêtise cette année c'est la roue libre
c'est vraiment la roue libre moi je suis
dans un laisser aller total et vous
aussi parce que vous cautionnez
totalement se laisser aller et même plus
que ça il vous plaît on est en train de
se tirer tous vers le bas et j'adore
[ __ ] je me suis régalé aujourd'hui je
rentrais me poser je suis heureux là
merci pour cette dose de bonheur a très
vite
[Musique]
mais